mon nom est nevaeh Havana après le jour, je suis
soulagé d'avoir une imprimante Je
travaille ici depuis 18 ans, donc en gros,
je fais surtout pour notre impression pour
les artistes, donc en gros, je suis en
train de maîtriser l'imprimante pour y arriver et je suis
ceux-ci dans le mur que vous voyez essaient
de prouver que les couleurs sont différentes comme sur
les papiers et les tailles de couleur en ce moment,
nous avons travaillé dans les sites réguliers
de notre impression identique au dessin original,
ce qui signifie qu'il n'a pas changé autant que possible,
mais parfois nous avons  pour le
changer, nous avons différentes épreuves sur le
mur, je dois faire des couleurs différentes, en
gros, nous partons des couleurs les plus
claires pour aller à la couleur sombre parce que nous
ne voulons pas perturber la couleur vive
pour enseigner cela et juste par couleur sombre
par  accident fondamentalement nous faisons étape par étape
par couleurs et celui-ci a environ
sept plaques plaques pour faire cette
magnifique belle impression donc
vous nous parliez du temps qu'il faut
pour faire le bureau je la preuve prendra environ
deux à trois jours  s tops mais j'axe l'
orientation vous prenez environ deux à
semaines cela dépend du nombre de couleurs impliquées
dans le nombre de tailles de papier à pipe
parfois le plus long que je prendrais est
presque un mois parce que je faisais un
papier de 34 x 40 pouces avec une grande presse  si
long pour l'Oscar de manger en quelque sorte l'
impression et pouvez-vous nous dire qui est l'
artiste et ce que nous voyons ici sur
l'image, ce nom d'artiste a
environ une semaine d'argent et maintenant il est aussi
un joli fabricant de  la pierre a coupé et
il a peint ça parce que je vous
chauffe essentiellement sur une nouvelle image lisse dans
une chaussure à talons hauts Johnny impliqué dans un
modèle unique mais il a juste restreint l'
image et c'est pourquoi il a dessiné cela pouvez-
vous nous dire comment vous décidez quelle
image  pour utiliser, nous sélectionnons essentiellement un autre
dessin original sur la table, puis nous
essayons de regarder autour de nous et de sélectionner le
Pingree que nous aimons et si cela fonctionne
vendre un produit vendable ou non, c'est ainsi que nous
sélectionnons notre dessin original, puis nous avons
demandé à nous d'entrer et de commencer
croquis  hing sur la plaque d'aluminium
ou la pierre c'est tout ce qu'ils ont vu avoir environ de l'
argent la semaine je lui ai demandé de revenir et de
faire cela sur la plaque d'aluminium c'est pourquoi
il est notre main en train de dessiner et d'après
ce que nous voyons ici lequel a été
choisi comme  le 12 de imprimer celui-ci en
fait comme celui-ci c'est là que vous
sélectionnez celui-ci et parmi tous ceux-
ci nous avons sélectionné parce que j'essaie de faire une
assiette différente même si cela sur un
papier blanc ce ne sont pas du papier crème nous l'
aimons plus pop  du blanc un peu
plus que d'autres couleurs ce genre d'
autres couleurs comme ce blanc est en quelque
sorte pour le fermer en fait que l'une
des vestes donc nous sélectionnons essentiellement
cela sur le papier Queen et vous passez
par le même processus pour chacun  image
qui vient ici oui, nous faisons en gros
nous faisons d'abord la couleur claire en allant à l'
obscurité le dernier serait le contour noir
puis nous allons après l'avoir prouvé puis nous avons
commencé à mettre sur le mur comme cet
affichage puis nous avons demandé aux artistes de venir le
long  avec t  l'imprimeur pour sélectionner lequel de
cette façon nous l'avons vérifié ou ou l'
artiste est susceptible de dire que nous c'est quand je les
aime que comment nous allons le sélectionner
donc fondamentalement de nos artistes moi-même et
facturer nous sélectionnons ceci c'est ce que nous et je
voulais juste  pour vous poser une question
sur vous-même, la collection d'imprimés cape dorset
est si célèbre et vous, les
imprimeurs, faites partie de ce qui rend
cela possible et je veux juste savoir pour vous
comment vous sentez-vous à l'idée de faire partie de
ce qui est considéré comme un tel phénomène et
quoi  est-ce que tu préfères ton travail
j'aime mon travail et je suis tellement fier de faire
partie de ces collections parce que euh
parfois je me rends compte que je suis l'un des
chanceux de vouloir imprimer North parce que
tu dois être spécial  compétences et
aussi quel genre d'image voudriez-vous
et devez vous reconnaître et nous
devons réfléchir à la meilleure façon de faire des
impressions ou de travailler avec les artistes et qu'avez
-vous fait avant de commencer à travailler ah
avant de travailler ici, je travaillais un
différents petits boulots comme un  travail pour la
menuiserie, je travaillais dans l'histoire
pour les garçons d'arrêt et d'autres trucs et d'une manière ou d'une
autre, j'aime mieux ce travail que les
autres qui finissent par rester ici
depuis, alors vous êtes passé de garçon de stock
à imprimeur pour l'un des
collections artistiques les plus célèbres d'Amérique du
Nord oui et parfois et regarde pourrais-
je penser à moi-même jambe je n'arrive pas à croire
que je travaille comme ce genre d'
art magnifique c'est très agréable j'aime ça merci
tellement de panique et je peux battre Oh
toi